what's going on everybody and welcome to
part three of the neural networks from
scratch series in this video we're going
to be doing is diving deeper into I
guess sort of cleaning this up but also
transitioning from very raw kind of
Python list code into using vectors and
matrices and stuff like that which is
the actual standard of doing deep
learning with really any programming
language so that's we're gonna be
getting into first I just want to bring
up a couple of things one is I've set up
a repository for neural networks from
scratch in X so I'll put a link in the
description but it's also pretty simple
github comm slash syntax slash n n FS IX
and I found that a lot of people were
saying they were indeed following along
in another programming language besides
Python so I set up the following a
repository both for if you want to
contribute so if you are following along
and you've got the each video part
you've been coding it if you want to
share it you can share it here also if
you're trying to follow along in another
language and you just want something to
reference you can also do that here so
check that out again I'll put a link in
description also thanks to everyone who
has contributed and supported the book
we're almost to like 2000 total people
on the book which is just crazy that's
that's really awesome I really
appreciate all the comments and
questions suggestions that edits all
that stuff in the document that's all
going really well and to put two
thousand people into the same document I
can certainly be hectic and it's been
pretty good so thank you guys very much
so let's go ahead and jump into the code
for today so there's a couple of things
that I want to do first of all we want
to simplify this code and I'm gonna save
you guys you don't have to follow along
coding this I just kind of want to show
moving from here to more dynamic code
before we kind of ditch at least this so
you can follow along for the first part
I suppose but anyway what we're gonna
say here is waits equals a list and then
basically just copy and paste these into
here so it's gonna be a list of lists in
this case and we'll just take
this could be pace to come down to this
last one here paste and then we're going
to do the exact same thing for bias so
we're gonna say bias is because now it's
multiples we're like two three and 0.5
if I'll fix my standards there and then
we can delete this and then delete this
code and boom I've already actually
coded this code so if you we're gonna be
using weights and biases like this soon
ish but not not even really in fact I'm
probably gonna go back we're gonna code
just a single neuron and then we'll go
to the three neurons with four input
it's all in this video but we're gonna
use a lot of the code so I'm probably
editing and undoing soon anyway
this is one way that we can simplify and
make much more dynamic so what we're
doing here is we're gonna zip together
weights and biases to start and if you
don't know what zip does it just kind of
combines two lists into a list of Lists
element-wise so in this case the first
element of this zipped list or the
zeroeth element of the zipped list will
be another list of the zeroeth weight in
the zero with bias and so on it just
combines two list element wise so we're
going to iterate over that and then
we're going to do input and the weight
and then we're going to zip those
together we're gonna say the neuron
output plus equals the inputs times the
weights and at the end we have the bias
append it together we can run that and
that is the output that we expected so
so yeah that's it's a cleaner more
dynamic way of doing influenced times
the weights plus the bias for a layer in
Python now we're still going to
transition to doing this in with numpy
and doing vectors and matrices and stuff
like that but this is a cleaner way and
if you're following along in some other
language obviously the the the answer is
to use loops so now the next thing I
want to touch before we get into the
numpy stuff is we're still getting a lot
of questions on weights and biases so I
just want to clear that up as quickly as
possible so weights and biases are these
knobs that I say we tune but really down
the line it's going to be the optimizer
that Tunes these
values in an attempt to fit to some data
and because we've got thousands or
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of these tunable parameters we can fit
so many things but the way that weights
and biases are impacting a neuron output
it's it's a it's a different way so you
could in theory have a neural network
it's I think it would be hard to have
one with just biases but even that's
probably possible for some simple tasks
you can also have a neural network with
just weights like you don't have to have
weights and biases necessarily but but
they're very helpful and biases are
almost never going to like negatively
impact anything so you want to have both
and and just real quickly I just want to
kind of drive home why are these
different so imagine you have some value
and we're going to say some value is
we're gonna make this 0.5 and then we're
gonna say you've got a weight and the
weight will be a 0.7 and for now we'll
do the same weight or the same value for
a bias so in this case what is a weight
going to do well the weight is gonna be
the weight time you know some value
times that weight right so it's a
multiplied thing oops weight and then
what's the bias gonna do so let's go
ahead and run that first actually so we
can see negative 0.35 now if we want to
do the same thing for bias let's go
ahead and current some value plus bias
run that and we get basically zero point
to hash tag programming problems anyway
so we have this obvious floating point
issue that's probably most programming
language are gonna have something some
issue like that but anyways you get the
idea so what what happened was we
converted from like so so weight was a
multiple of this negative so it stayed
negative whereas bias what bias has done
is it has off set the the value so
depends on what you're trying to do but
in the in at some point we're going to
get into activation functions and these
are functions that kind of that
determine that final that final output
before it becomes an input to another
layer or maybe even the final output to
your your network in general so
what's happening here is they're just
doing two different things the weight is
just changing like the magnitude the
bias is actually offsetting it it's no
different than the bias and y equals MX
plus B for the equation of a line so in
this case what we've seen is we could go
from a negative to a positive
using bias but we could of course go
from a negative to a positive using
weight right we can make this a negative
0.7 right and we can run that and wow we
got to a positive but but this would be
a problem because what if we started
with a positive value well obviously it
becomes a negative at the end but this
whole time whatever some value was after
bias it stayed a positive value because
all it does is offset so these are just
two different tools that help in two
different ways and and that's it so
anyways I think this will make more
sense as we especially get into
activation functions and like rectified
linear it should be unbelievably obvious
what bias can do for you
but anyway just for now hopefully you
can see that there are two different
tools doing two different things and if
we have millions of these little tools
that we can sort of tweak we can change
the overall kind of outputs now with
that in mind let's get into
transitioning into real more real
mathematics um rather than this this
stuff so we're gonna get into numpy now
and start talking about vectors and
matrices and dot products and all these
things and we're gonna start by talking
about shape as boring as that might
sound um if you've ever worked with any
deep learning frameworks I'm willing to
bet that you have hit errors regarding
shape I know that's one of the most
common questions I ever get with with
just deep learning and like tensorflow
chaos all this stuff is people have a
shape error and understanding shape is
the first step to understanding how
really the rest of this works so it's
essential we get this understood so this
we're gonna be talking about now so the
concept of shape is that basically it is
at each dimension what's the size of
that dimension so in this case we've got
a list of four elements this is a one
dimensional list and we have because we
have four elements that means the shape
is just
for this is also a 1d array and it's a
vector so a list in Python can be an
array with numpy and if it is if it's
just a simple list then it's a
one-dimensional array in numpy and then
in mathematics a list is a vector now
imagine a scenario where we have two
lists contained in a list right in
python we call that a list of lists or
LOL for short in numpy this is a
two-dimensional array because that first
list has how many lists two lists now
each lists how many elements does each
list have for now this is the first time
we're kind of showing an example of how
arrays have to be what's called
homologous this means at each dimension
they need to have the same size for each
dimension so imagine in this case if
this second list in this list of lists
only had three elements could we come up
with could we say what the shape is no
because in one case it's a two by maybe
four and then the other case would be a
two by three so so it could never be an
array if it did not have a homologous
shape to it like this one does so in
this case this is a two dimensional
array it is also a matrix and a matrix
is simply a rectangular array so a list
of vectors is a matrix now again imagine
a scenario where you've got three of
these lists of lists contained within a
list what are we looking at a list of
lists of lists or lolol this shape
because we've got three lists of lists
the first at the first dimension we have
three elements at the second dimension
we have two and the third dimension we
have four this is a three dimensional
array so finally the last container type
I'll just briefly mention is a tensor so
if you've ever played with tensorflow or
heard of tensor flow you might wonder
well what is a tensor and then some
tutorials might call things tensors so
put extremely simply a tensor is an
object that can be represented as an
array a tensor is not just an array but
in the context of doing deep learning in
programming a tensor is rep
and as an array so you will work with
tensors in the array form so just in
case you're getting information from
other sources and so on you might be
really confused like what is the tensor
there you go it's an object that can be
represented as an array so getting into
our code again now that we've learned
what vectors and matrices and arrays and
how they all kind of go together now
we've learned that let's remind
ourselves what are we trying to do here
we are trying to do inputs times the way
it's plus bias so bias is a vector
inputs is currently a vector and weights
or a matrix of vectors so how do we how
do we multiply because what's what we
want to do we want to multiply this
vector times this matrix of vectors how
do we do that well the way that we do
that is with what's called the dot
product so or the matrix product but in
terms of numpy it is the dot product
handles for both of these scenarios so
let's talk about dot product so to
illustrate the dot product let's say
we've got two vectors vector a and
vector B now the dot product is you
multiply element wise the values in
these vectors and you add that all
together so at the zeroeth index of a
times B at the zeroeth index plus a
first v times B first if plus a at the
second times B at the second so the main
thing to note here is the dot product of
two vectors results in a scalar single
value all right getting back to our code
let's try to employ the dot product but
first we're going to do it just with a
single neuron so the four inputs one set
of weights one bias and then we'll do
the full layer of neurons and I'm not
just doing this to waste time I'm doing
this to drive home a point about how dot
product and matrix product really works
so that when we go and then translate to
doing things in batches you're gonna
understand cuz if we don't do it this
way
I assure you many of you guys won't
understand I can at least attest
personally I didn't actually understand
what was going on until I I learned a
little more about how this actually
works so hopefully I can save you guys
that pain point so the first thing we're
going to do is get rid of this code here
and then I'm gonna save a copy of this
because we're gonna need it very soon
but for now I am going to reduce weights
to just being one set of weights and
then biases will actually be two and now
it's just a bias and then we are going
to do the dot product so we're going to
use import numpy as NP if you don't have
numpy for whatever reason you can pip
install numpy you might have to do pip 3
installed on PI or Python 3.7 - M pip
install whatever you should know how to
pip install if you're having a problem
feel free to leave a comment below but I
kind of expect that everybody following
along understands how to install
packages but I'm happy to help you if
you don't know so so make sure you get
numpy and to do dot product it's
actually unbelievably simple so we're
going to say output equals NP dot dot
and then we want to pass either the
matrices or the vectors alone of that we
want to do dot or matrix product of in
this case you you might want to say
inputs weights and then plus bias and
this will work we'll run it so print
print print output it doesn't work it
gives us that four point eight that we
were expecting to see but really we're
gonna do weights time times the inputs
in this case both of these are a vector
so it doesn't really matter which one
comes first we'll get the exact same
answer in this case but very soon it is
going to matter greatly so so so first
looking at this code doing MP dot
weights inputs plus the bias let's
review what happened here before we go
to a full layer so again reviewing what
just happened we did an MP dot weights
inputs plus bias now what's happening
here is when we do that dot product of
those two vectors they're just
multiplying element-wise each element at
the same index of both of these vectors
and then adding all of that together so
just that dot product alone returned to
us a two point eight then we add the
bias of 2.0 and that gives us the final
answer of four point eight so pretty
simple to understand I think up to this
point and now let's get into doing a
products with a layer of neurons okay so
coming back to our code let's do a dot
product of a layer of neurons so that's
why I went ahead and saved a copy here
so I'm gonna copy that come over here
paste that and then everything stays the
same weights inputs and then bias sees
right and now we will illustrate why
weights came first so let's go ahead and
first run that and we can see we get the
output that we again expected from
seeing this we've seen these operations
already so what's happening in this dot
product shouldn't be you know beyond you
because you've seen it in very raw
Python code but that is the output that
we wanted now if originally remember we
were able to interchange inputs and
weights because inputs and weights were
they were both just a vector and so the
order of two vectors is not going to
change the output of the dot product but
now what is inputs is a vector still
weights is actually a matrix right it's
a matrix containing vectors so this is
different so the first element in this
dot product when you do a dot product
with numpy the the first element you
pass is how the return is going to be
indexed so in this case what do we
actually want back right we want those
outputs like what are we modeling here
we're modeling three neurons how did we
know what was the difference that
changed when we wanted three neurons the
the at least before we did the plus bias
so the only the difference in the in the
dot product the difference was well we
have three sets of weights this is how
we knew this is three neurons so because
of that because we want things in the we
want that output to be the values from
the neurons we want this that's what we
want we pass weights as that first input
because we want things indexed by those
weight sets that that's what we want and
in fact if we first passed inputs and
then weights we're gonna see this
doesn't even work right it throws an
error and again this was probably the
start of something similar that you've
probably seen before if you
overworked with any other deep learning
library is you get these weird shape
errors and without a really good
understanding of what are the actual
atomic calculations that are trying to
be done here you're gonna get these and
have absolutely no clue like what what
have I done so okay so converting this
back to weights and inputs if it's not
already clear what's happening basically
this first thing is going to be broken
down into doing dot products of this and
then dot product of this and by dot
products I mean this times this right so
this dot this and then it's gonna be
this dot this and so on it's just gonna
iterate through the this this matrix of
vectors so again let's just run X I
don't like looking at the air again
let's visualize what has happened in
this case okay so to review what's gone
on here we've got outputs as MP dot
weights and input so let's talk about
just that for now and what's gonna
happen here is because weights is a
matrix of three vectors it's gonna do
this dot product three times so as you
can see it's MP dot weights you know
zero with vector so weights zero is a
vector of weights so now we can actually
do the dot product that we know and love
and so what's going to be returned to us
from doing a dot product or NP dot dot
of a matrix of vectors and just a vector
it's going to return to us in numpy form
this will be an array of these values
that will be the dot product of the
zeroeth weights and inputs and then the
dot product of the first tooth weights
and inputs and the dot product of the
second weights and inputs and then after
that all we're going to do is add these
two vectors together to get our final
output values
okay so that's the conversion of
everything into numpy terms and more
mathematics terms this is the way that
you are going to be seeing the
calculation it's the dot product of
weights and inputs plus the bias that's
that's how all the notation that you're
gonna see is going to be doing this so
moving forward now you should understand
exactly what's happening there and then
also hopefully be understanding how the
dot product and numpy is actually
working because not only are we going to
need to understand how that works when
we do a layer pretty soon we're gonna be
doing things in a batch so up until this
point our input data has actually just
been a 1d right or a vector of a single
sample but soon what we're gonna be
doing instead is passing a batch of
these samples and now input data rather
than just being a 1d array or a vector
it's actually gonna be a 2d array or a
matrix so hopefully now that we've
covered shape and what vectors are
matrices and dot product and you
hopefully have a really good grasp of
how that's working I'd strongly advise
you not to leave this video if if you
don't yet understand so please ask
questions below also hopefully we've
cleared up the questions about weights
versus bias there's just two different
tools for approximating something and
weights times the inputs plus the bias
is similar to the equation for a line y
equals MX plus B something like that
right so here's an example where X is
your input Y is your output and now
we're going to just be modifying weight
you can see how it impacts the equation
for that line similarly as we adjust
bias we can make changes to the line
that way and you can see that by
adjusting bias we're able to graph
certain lines that we just simply could
not have graphed with just simply
adjusting the weight alone so the
difference is as well as the actual
benefits and use cases for weights
versus biases become even more apparent
once we get to activation functions you
don't necessarily need to know how
rectified linear working we're going to
get to that in a little bit but you
should be able to see at least visually
that by adjusting weights there's a just
a completely different impact
than adjusting for bias and basically
bias is going to at least in terms of
her activation function help determine
whether or not this neuron is actually
firing at all and if so to what degree
again right now we're just kind of we're
just making up values here this has no
meaning soon we'll work with a dataset
that has a little more meaning and then
when we get towards once we figure out
the basics of neural networks we'll use
a real data set and hopefully have even
more meaning but one baby step at a time
this is it's such a complicated topic in
so many ways it's very easy to skip over
things and gloss over things and get to
the quote-unquote sexy part of deep
learning but in order to get there and
really understand you got to go through
here so hopefully you guys are enjoying
again the series is in conjunction with
the book and NFS i/o also check out
neural networks from scratch in X pretty
cool also if you're curious the person
who has done the scratch variant is
Daniel who's the co-author of the book
he's also the one doing the animation so
if you're really enjoying these
animations shouts out to Daniel he's
also done a short video of programming a
fully working neural network in scratch
the programming language which is
absolutely absurd I will put a link in
the description you can check it out
it's not too long and it is absolutely
insane also some people have been asking
and noting the similarities between the
animations and three blue one Brown
animations and that is because we are
using the manum package so this is the
package from three blue one brown and
basically what we've done is we've kind
of built a framework and by we I mean
Daniel on top of three blue one brown to
do the animation so if you guys are
really enjoying the animations again
shouts out to Daniel also I'm just as
excited as you guys are I think the
animations are an awesome addition to
the channel so thanks to three blue one
brown and also Daniel for writing that
code kind of on top of it to get this
done so anyway that's all for now if you
guys have questions comments concerns
whatever you know the deal leave them
below otherwise I will see you guys in
another video